[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in chris sims football night
in america pro football talk live
co-host with mike florio
um
where do you stand with this situation
as the browns move forward
well uh you know i know we've talked
about it in the past i'm one you know
right off the bat as far as like you
know baker mayfield i think you make
good points you know it is up to the
organization the head coach to evaluate
it for you know what is best for our
football team and yeah injuries oh
missed the week of practice kazakova
maybe that's not when you play the guy
you're right oh that's right he threw
four interceptions in that game you know
i mean so your point is real there
there's no doubt about it as far as
baker mayfield and the browns and that
whole situation going forward i think
you know we talked about this maybe
about a month ago i mean um i expect
baker mayfield to be back but like the
the the red carpet or the you know the
rose parade or the the honeymoon it's
over we're at that point here now
officially there's no doubt whether they
want to make it more of a competition
between case keenum are bringing another
qb to have them there as a backup plan
but i i don't think we're going to see
baker mayfield long-term extension no
way there's no way i would do that if
i'm the cleveland browns they
they exercise their right to get the
fifth year option and they gotta
continue to evaluate this as they go
forward but but do you pull the band-aid
now though chris because this is still a
really talented team let's say
desean watson's in play in cleveland
let's say russell wilson's in play
let's say
jimmy garoppolo let's say
uh aaron rodgers like you know if you're
the browns i think you got to look at
big picture instead of going well we
don't want baker long term but at 18
million dollars next year that's not bad
for a starting quarterback and then at
what point are you saying we're wasting
another season or does it become a
distraction for the browns and baker
mayfield with that contract
extension next year
well i i you know again
if you have the chance to get a watson
or wilson or somebody like that then
fine that then okay maybe i would think
about like you're talking about ripping
the band-aid off and going okay these
are proven entities we know what they
are we're not exactly sure of what baker
mayfield is
now i'm not going to throw but but you
better have somebody like that i guess
is what i would say at least in my
opinion i'm not saying i'm right but we
have seen enough spurts through baker
mayfield's career to know there is some
talent and he can do some good things on
the football field we saw that at the
end of the 2020 season you know they had
the chiefs on their heels in the playoff
game he played very good down the
stretch last year so there is at least
some evidence to go hey wait he can make
some game-changing plays and throws and
lead our team there's some things to
like there i'm not trading them away for
jimmy garoppolo no i'm definitely not
i'm going to play the angle of there's
still more potential in baker mayfield's
ultimate talent than a guy like jimmy
garoppolo um but
again you know i don't think you just
throw him overboard for for for anybody
there's issues there in cleveland you
know the guys doing the telecast last
night explained it i think in a lot of
ways too you know what what was the
approach to that football game what the
hell was going on there baker mayfield
was beat up no doubt about it they
obviously couldn't protect him you know
stefanski one of the i was one of those
that was not a huge fan of the hire in
cleveland because i've always been
underwhelmed by the passing offense of
the stefanski scheme that's what i've
never and i look at that and go okay you
know the talent's okay in the passing
game but the scheme is underwhelming to
me and it's a little predictable so i do
give baker mayfield a little bit of the
benefit of that too uh but there's going
to be some tough decisions that have to
be made there in cleveland because as
you know as we all know it's one of the
most disappointing stories or teams in
football this year would you rather have
jalen hurts or baker mayfield oh
well you got to have a if you're going
to go jalen hurts right and i was i'm i
and you know i i took l
with the jalen hurts thing before the
year i didn't make him one of my top 40
quarterbacks you know now
at that time i kind of was more
evaluating as they're going to try to
make him a drop back quarterback and
make him you know fill up rivers in the
the los angeles chargers system
you know but i i've certainly have been
proven wrong and
and and and where i'm wrong is they went
all in on you know
he's a better runner than i thought he
was and of course they have a great
offensive line so they're playing a
different style of football you have to
be committed to play a certain style of
football i think with you have jalen
hurts it is going to be a lamar jackson
type offense you're not going to get
surgical like precision drop back
passing and a guy that's going to be
capable of going 30 for 35 for 340 yards
from jalen hurts so that's where it's
different you got to figure out what
kind of offense you're going to run
that's why it's a tough one dan
traditional offense i want baker
mayfield we're going to go all in on the
all running game and all that then yes
i'll go jaylen hurts there
we're talking to chris sims pro football
talk live co-host and also contributor
to
sunday night football all right tampa
bay buccaneers moving forward you don't
have chris godwin you don't have antonio
brown defense hasn't played up to its
standards that we saw in the super bowl
uh leonard fournette has been out you
still have tom brady
yeah what do you think the playoff
future
of the buccaneers is well it's scary
right now it is you know again they're
they're
a beautifully constructed football team
but i i don't even know for as well
constructed as they are i don't even
know if they can overcome this amount of
injuries and go for a super ball run so
i do think like the threshold of
injuries has hit a point where i go
it makes me look at them as a different
football team you know shaq barrett jpp
not in there levante david you know
secondary been banged up have issues
there you mentioned all the guys on the
offensive side of the ball you know so
at full strength or close to full
strength i certainly still think they're
one of the best teams in the nfc but i
need to kind of see how these next two
weeks go as far as the health of their
football team and where they can get by
wild card weekend i think that would
make me dictate that but like i'm
definitely a little concerned right now
dan there's no doubt about it where
maybe four weeks ago i would have gone
ah i'm okay they're gonna they're gonna
make a run and get this together they're
kind of just sleepwalking right now they
know what they're capable of they'll
step on the gas pedal uh right now i'm
kind of like i'm not sure if they can do
this with this group of guys here
is antonio brown an issue or does he
have issues because all of a sudden tom
brady says he needs help well did he
need help just because what happened on
sunday or has he always needed help and
we keep kind of masking the issue here
i i think so yes i mean i think he's
always needed help you've kind of always
heard that from every place he goes but
it just kind of gets swiped under the
rug and they the next team gets them and
goes oh damn he works hard and he's
talented what there was issues at the
other place
we haven't seen that you know and then
of course it slowly comes about well
again i'm not trying to play
psychologists here or anything like that
but it certainly seems at surface level
or what we're seeing that there are
issues there and the bucks feel burned i
mean they just stuck their neck out
there for a guy who had a fake vaccine
card and be made them a spectacle of the
sport for a week and how they were going
to handle it and put the nfl in a tough
spot and then here we go and you you
cause this you know distraction disaster
uh whatever you want to call it on
sunday i've never seen anything like it
so you know i i think there's a little
bit of both there at play i guess he you
know he he does need help uh it seems
like but hey we had enough evidence to
know that this was a possibility with
him and when you play with fire you get
burned sometimes and their their butt
got burned on this one
yeah it's
it's just like you've got to get another
chance yeah you think so
well i just that that's the mean the
million dollar question
you know we know talent talks in the nfl
and a lot of issues get get pushed to
the side when a guy can still get open
or still play at a high level to where
that i would think the bucks right now
are kind of trying to play they're
trying to look if they can suspend him
without pay or keep him on their roster
so a team like the chiefs or the rams or
the packers don't pick him up and get
him for a six-week you know clean slate
and it ends up kicking their butt and
ends up you know kicking their butt in
the playoffs of the super bowl i think
that's what they're probably worried
about now yeah i think that tampa that
you know there's salary cap issues like
how can they
do it that minimizes even further damage
and doesn't allow him to get out of jail
and go play for one of these other teams
um
do you love joe burrow or do you love
joe bro oh
i love joe burrow
i love him i really do and he's gotten
better in the things that i questioned
about you know first off he's he's the
magic man he's just cool joe whatever
you want to call him he's unbelievable
he's the natural he really is the
natural at the position i had one
question about him coming out in the
draft just overall arm strength you know
that was the one thing i went and just
went man i'm going to give him the edge
on herbert erbert has more physical
ability you know burro can make all the
throws but you know i wish there was a
little bit more power in the arm all he
talked about in the off season was
improving his arm proving some mechanics
to throw the ball with more power you
see that you know so he just has
everything he's got every club in the
bag he's so cool and calm under pressure
he's one of the most slippery sobs in
football in the pocket work in the
pocket i mean come on the bangles were a
dysfunction and we were going man does
joe burrow really want to go there and
the guy and the player are so awesome in
both aspects that now we look at the
bengals as a different thing we're going
well this is the most exciting team
we've seen in football they got a bright
future and that's all because of him and
that's why i love joe burrow if you
could start your franchise with one
quarterback from the 2004 draft eli
philip rivers or ben
roethlisberger knowing what you know now
yeah
um
i'm going to go with big ben i am i know
again i'm a i'm a sucker for for talent
i guess more than anything i respect the
hell out of those other two guys
i do but big ben to me
uh it's just the best of the three
period you know consistently playing at
a high level and i think the biggest
thing too dan that all that where i give
him the edge is just
when you know
he's capable of carrying the team when
things aren't great especially in his
prime i mean he had some years there
where
they went to the super bowl with like
arguably one of the three four five
worst offensive lines in the game and
won the super bowl that's really rare
for that to happen and that's because he
was so gifted you know his ability to
throw with people around him or you know
take those little fred flintstone steps
around the pocket and move around and
pump faking and people hanging on them
and he's just oh i'm still gonna throw
it and get a first down
that's where i give him a little edge
it's a little different because i don't
think he was necessarily studying the
playbook or grinding film i think he was
you know he's a little bit more like
just backyard football but it's also why
i love him and i i would take him over
the other two
packers have any issues
yes
i question
you know won the defense to a degree i
mean how can you not i know let's let's
forget the vikings game last week
without kirk cousins you know all the
weeks before that man run game pass game
teams have been having their way with
the packers defense i question the
packer in a year where there's no great
team in the nfl and it's really going to
come down to match-ups and these
playoffs
i just question
the high-end talent of the packers i'm
one of the i think than one of the few
out there that i just go they're good i
get it they have aaron rodgers he's the
mvp
but can you really get to the super
super bowl by not messing games up
execution and just riding devonta adams
and aaron rodgers that's where i don't
know they're gonna end up playing teams
in the playoffs here of course are well
coached and i believe have more talent
than them and that's where i'm a little
bit
you know
not sure about if the packers can really
get to the super bowl and win the super
bowl
i think what they do well though is
they're mixing in the run a lot more
and and that makes them i i love a team
that gives you that option of running
the football look back on the buccaneers
with leonard fournette last year like he
was a real difference maker all of those
running backs that brady had when he was
in new england you you have to have that
element there you you can't be
one-dimensional i don't think you have
to have a defense that has the ability
to stop you when they need to and i
think being able to run the football
and and i see that with green bay
defense is getting some of their star
players back back to ari's coming back
you got two running backs with green bay
you have home field advantage maybe a
true home field advantage and you know
that's why i like green bay yeah i i i
hear you there and jail alexander and
him getting back will be a huge thing i
mean if they can get him back i mean
he's one healthy definitely one of the
five best corners in football zadaria
smith on the defensive side of the ball
would be another huge addition because
again like i said i
i i i question their top end talent and
i think your offense running game thing
is a real thing i mean we've really only
seen the chiefs here in the last 10 12
years be able to go and win a super bowl
and do that without like a run game yeah
they're one of the few teams we've seen
do that and okay but they have like some
other really really special attributes
that have helped them overcome that uh
you're right though with green bay and
then with rogers at the helm they never
waste plays they're very unbelievable at
executing managing the football game and
they just don't make mistakes especially
on the offensive side of the ball and
that's what makes them tough to to beat
the to your point dan thank you bud good
to talk to you again thank you chris
thanks guys be good have a go tell all
those jerks i said hello hey jerks he
says hello chris sims pro football talk
live co-host and contributor to football
night in america